Це 27- річний Роман Дяченко.
Він один із перших в Україні сімейних лікарів, який
став приватним підприємцем.
- Заходьте, сідайте.
Нагадайте свою фамілію?
- Ой, це хороший лікар.
Відкрити особистий кабінет для прийому пацієнтів
у Христинівці на Черкащині йому дозволила
медреформа від МОЗ. Консультації безкоштовні.
За кожного пацієнта лікарю платить Національна служба здоров’я.
- Добре, звичайно, чому ж не добре?
Якщо в рази, в два-три рази, зросла заробітна плата лікаря офіційно.
А це 71-річний Георгій Антонович. Він працює
у тій же Христинівці, щоправда, в державній амбулаторії.
На відміну від Романа Дяченка,
свій максимум пацієнтів - у 1800 чоловік - він не набрав.
Лише трохи більше трьохсот. Йому реформа не подобається.
- Це свого роду приниження для лікарів, щоб вони
ходили під хати і агітували, що, мовляв, записуйтеся
до мене, до Іванова, а до Петрова - ні, бо він гірший.
Навесні 2018 року в Україні стартувала масштабна
реформа первинної ланки медицини. Згідно з нею,
кожен може вільно обирати для себе лікаря,
підписавши з ним декларацію. Так пацієнти
отримують особистого лікаря, а медик - можливість
отримати гідну заробітну плату. Її нараховує
Національна служба здоров’я за принципом "гроші йдуть за пацієнтом".
Базовий тариф - 370 гривень на пацієнта.
За пенсіонерів держава платить удвічі більше,
а найбільше - за дітей до 5-ти років: майже 1,5 тисячі гривень.
Після підписання декларації пацієнт може
приходити за консультацією хоч кожен день.
Головне - аби по запису і вчасно, жартує Роман.
Своїх пацієнтів він консультує також по телефону.
- Слухаю вас.
Це на половинку таблетки…
Це нове і світле приміщення молодий лікар орендує.
Утім, аби укомплектувати його, довелося взяти
кредит на сто тисяч гривень. На власні кошти
придбав також медичні шафи для медикаментів,
канапу, ваги і ростомір. Адже Національна служба здоров'я
співпрацює лише з тими закладами, які відповідно оснащені.
- Найдорожчим є кардіограф і його перевірка раз на рік.
Кардіограф десь, якщо не помилясь, до 13 тисяч,
перевірка щороку - 800 чи 1000 гривень.
Гроші, які щомісяця надходять від держави,
Роман Дяченко розподіляє сам: скільки з них
піде на заробітну плату, а скільки - на утримання кабінету.
За півроку розрахувався за кредитом і тепер думає
про подальше розширення свого кабінету.
Хоче найняти медсестру. А з часом придбати
автомобіль, аби швидко доїжджати до хворих. Утім,
планам заважає постійне підвищення цін.
Цього місяця, приміром, удвічі зросли
лабораторні аналізи. А ще його непокоять
судові позови довкола виконувачки обов'язків
міністра охорони здоров'я України Уляни Супрун
та загроза згортання реформ. Це - найбільший страх.
- Я спакую валізу і поїду десь далеко.
Я це всім кажу. Не Супрун - реформи.
А як рушійна сила - це Уляна Супрун. Це моя думка.
Тим часом для лікаря Георгія Антоновича
світлі часи в медицині вже минули. Від потужної
залізничної лікарні, де він пропрацював майже 45 років,
по суті, нічого не залишилося. Пустують не лише
окремі кабінети, а цілі корпуси. Зі сльозами на очах
перераховує, що тут колись було.
- Душі й УЗД, ендоскопія, рентгени, лабораторія,
функціональна діагностика…
Коли медицину первинного рівня відокремили
від вторинного рівня, влада Христинівки вирішила,
що утримувати лікарню на околиці невигідно.
Скоротила штат зі 130 чоловік до 30.
Тепер тут лише амбулаторія.
- Якщо гайморит чи перелом, то направляють за три кілометри,
аби зробили знімок. А раніше все було поруч,
ось тут, розумієте. Якщо молодші мають транспорт,
то вони поїдуть, а бабусі й дідусі кажуть:
Антонович, ми туди не дійдемо.
Така ситуація типова для цілої України. Утім,
на думку чиновників МОЗ, такий перерозподіл
медичних закладів зробить послуги якіснішими,
адже утримувати вузькокваліфікованого фахівця і
дороге обладнання десь у глибинці невигідно.
Натомість у селах вкрай необхідно поліпшити
первинну медицину. У цьому районі, приміром,
жодної з восьми сільських амбулаторій не закрили.
А після капітального ремонту першої міської
амбулаторії перейдуть і до сільських.
- Ніхто не може похвалитися тим, що геть усе так добре.
Але я знаю точно, що ті гроші,
які нам присилає Національна служба здоров’я України,
йдуть на заробітні плати і на закупку деяких медикаментів.
А кошти на ремонти, на енергоносії, знеболювальне
на це все виділяє кошти місцевий бюджет.
Нині договори з Національною службою здоров’я
уклали майже всі медичні заклади первинної ланки в Україні.
Зросла й кількість лікарів - приватних підприємців.
Якщо влітку минулого року таких було
зареєстровано лише 5 по всій Україні, то нині їх уже близько 100.
Їхня кількість зростатиме, переконаний Роман Дяченко.
А там, гляди, реформа змінить і мислення пацієнтів.
- Буває, приносять шоколадки.
Ще люди не відвикли, що не треба нічого
нести лікарю. Я маю на увазі ті, які задекларовані.
Нічого не зробиш.
Треба перевчати.
- Що кажете?
- Кажу, що я не їм солодкого,
не п’ю алкоголю.
А що ви їсте, докторе? Кажу: м’ясо їм.
Але м’яса ще не приносили.
Молодий лікар поволі привчає своїх пацієнтів, що
до сімейного лікаря можна і треба йти лише з медичною карткою.